alors hier soir aussi gilles isabelle se
sont embrassés si vous n'avez pas eu la
chance de voir cette séquence dit non on
va la recevoir il ya eu beaucoup de
temps sur les réseaux sociaux
je croyais pas que ça allait prendre une
telle ampleur c'est ce que cette
séquence a été vu et revu et il ya eu
énormément de réactions que je vais vous
lire dans un instant regardez c'était
hier soir et fait gaffe alors tu sais
comme on l'appelle dans le milieu
comment le reptile
[Applaudissements]
non
alors tu es bon je vais te demander
parce que tu es un téléfilm ailleurs à
l'émission tu n'arrives ai dit la vérité
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui ont dit
voilà qui se sont plaints te dis oui
pour l'heure pour leur conjoint c'est
chaud voilà il y en a beaucoup qui ont
dit voilà que c'était un peu chaud qui
se tend la pensée toi dis la vérité
ben c'est un happening après année dans
touche pas à mon poste donc c'est normal
de s'amuser en fin de match
non pas du tout voilà c'est vrai qu'ici
c'est voilà si on fait des ont fait des
happenings ça ici voilà qui ont dit oui
comment ils vont faire avec leurs
conjoints se sont inquiétés pour vous
jean-michel moi ça m'a surtout choqué au
nom de l'hygiène bucco-dentaire pasqua
s'était alors je vais vous dire on va
alors ok dit une connerie une langue
parce que il est prouvé que l an et moi
je précise que je n'ai pas mis la langue
mais il dans les justement le circuit
nous sommes d'un baiser permet une
immunité d2 et permet ne jamais rien dit
alors elle j'aime pas ma cgil gilles a
eu des gros soucis
bah je vous le dis on sait mais voilà
donc il va nous raconter ça dans
l'instant il voulait dire et je pense
que tu as quelque chose à dire ce soir
dans un instant gilles parce que ça
s'est pas passé comme tu voulais après
ce baiser
voilà après c'est vrai que je sais que
c'est de l'amitié voilà c'est un bisou
d'amitié mais il n'a pas été pris comme
tel matthieu delormeau c'est pas la
peine de chauffer quoi ben alors
embrassons nous comme deux amis
c'est pas un bisou d'amitié ces packs
est en difficulté dans un instant les
chéris également on aura tous les sujets
du jour il s'est passé plein de choses
aujourd'hui je vous le dit et on va
revenir là dessus bien entendu il ya du
gossip et surtout gilles telles
révélations à faire fatah quelque chose
à dire voilà dans un instant j'espère
que ça va bien se passer pour toi et
sache que pire des cas je serai là je
sais vous êtes toujours là ouais je sais
pas isabelle vous ça va même mon mari
regarde pas donc ses copains qui vont
lui dire bête pour moi fab et une
chaudière au tchad
on va revenir sur le bisou entre gilles
et isabelle alors gilles hier donc nous
avons embrassé isabelle dans l'émission
puisque c'était voilà ta journée du
câlin peut-être un kalidou tout doux
tout doux et après vous avez déçus on
m'avait dit ce soir j'aimerais faire un
truc à l'antenne oui se passe alors ce
qui s'est passé c'est que moi j'ai fait
ça vous me connaissez bien je suis
spontanée terre journée du câlin en
toute amitié j'ai embrassé isabelle et
moi je me jette à fond dans le bon
esprit de l'émission et puis au fil de
l'émission je me suis demandé si j'avais
eu raison et à la fin de l'émission il
ya quelqu'un ici qui est très important
pour moi qui je m'adresse quand j'ai des
difficultés qui ont deux conseillères
conjugales
c'est kelly ah merde non pas du tout et
je suis allé voir kelly à la fin de
l'émission et la kelly m'a tout de suite
expliqué que ce que j'avais fait n'était
pas bien
oui un nom quand il est venu me voir je
me sur le coup je me suis dit ils
abusent parce que on peut faire un petit
bisou comme ça pour rigoler mais là de
la sphère un baiser langoureux comme ça
où on voit ce qui sort ce qui rentre
moi je suis
en science agence cela en toute amitié
pour gilles je lui ai dis sincèrement
gilles on est amis donc je vais te dire
ce que j'en pense vraiment et je lui ai
dit oui je pense que là fatou bâ va être
dégoûté enfin comme si ça faisait trop
et que est comme moi j'aurais été à la
base de fatou bâ j'aurais été super
énervé de voir ça et on sait que tu te
donnes à fond pour l'antenne on sait que
tu donnes tout pour l'antenne mais il
faut des fois que tu apprennes un petit
peu at mesurer et à appréhender les
conséquences que ça qu'on t'aime aussi j
alors alors qu'est-ce que donc juste
après kelly j'ai regardé mon téléphone
et j'avais un sms que je vous dirai pas
bien avec 4 mo de fatou j'ai compris que
la situation est une icône a séduit
c'était un peu ce genre là mais j'ai
appelé fatto qui n'a pas accepté qu'ils
avaient regardé qui n'a pas accepté
est ce que je voudrais dire c'est que un
homme doit assumer ses responsabilités
donc je peux parler à fatou bâ
directement les yeux dans les yeux
alors là c'est castaldi mais bon au mali
ont regardé ce que vous m'autorisez a
bien sûr fait tout ce que vous voulez
alors chéri non mais sans déconner mais
je vous mets les dés de faire des
affaires vas-y gilles tu as trouvé que
je t'avais manquer de respect et d jean
cyril en parler ont également trouvé ça
c'est que j'ai manqué de respect donc
j'assume mes responsabilités je m'en
excuse je voulais absolument pas de
faire de mal j'ai fait une erreur
c'était dans l'esprit de l'émission qui
est bon enfant que tu adores tu sais je
sais que tu adores cyril s'était c'est
vraiment uniquement moi c'est pas
isabelle je m'excuse aussi auprès
d'alain c'est moi pour parler
vulgairement j'ai déconné chérie je m'en
excuse mais c'est de me rattraper je
vais essayer de te parler
je suis désolé je t'ai manqué de respect
est ce que je voudrais dire chérie c'est
que je t'aime
tu me dis bien ce combat nous leurs mots
c'est très beau ce qu'il a dit c'est la
musique que je quitte mon s'étaient
battus rigole mais gilles il est
vraiment dans la merde pour parler
vulgairement la vie aussi si je peux
tout à l'heure et j'adore j2 signe enfin
parler tu résides m'excuser gerig et
pour la musique qui était juste sahara
par rapport à gilles dumas appartenait
par les avants ben pardon jr sinon
j'aime alors c'est hallucinant moi tout
le monde s'en cogne des pâtes mais vous
l'avez vous n'avez pas eu de problème
non l'instant ça peut être une bombe à
retardement au feu quand vous aurez
besoin de fire puis pourquoi
voilà donc gilles vous avez eu un souci
donc vos sawi abat clairement la
situation est délicate et encore une
fois je la met totalement on espère en
tout cas que ça va se résorber et siphat
ou me regarde je sais qu'elle m'aime
beaucoup fin tout je t'aime énormément
et tu peux te dire que gilles est très
très amoureux et que gilles vraiment il
ne fait il est irréprochable
voilà il ne fait aucun écart ni grand
écart je te le dis est vraiment tu peux
avoir confiance en lui c'est quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel
et lisa belle ainsi si bien entendu vous
nous en parlera est pour l'instant no
soucy motion alors c'est tout pour les
gouttes
ben non parce que moi n'a pas fait les
me préciser que je n'ai pas mis la
langue puisque tout le monde plusieurs
personnes dans les réseaux d'accord il
sage et plus ça comme un baiser de
cinéma et essai qui mangent j'aime
beaucoup la corée vous étes trés photo
elle doit être très tranquille là dessus
et ça tout j'aime beaucoup et donc moi
je dis pas non plus ne manquez de
respect oui mon mari n'est à fatou n'est
à personne
la zone avait oublié sa belle bon bah
voilà très bien géraldine la voie de la
sagesse vous dites quoi moi je comprend
effectivement que fatou a été touché
meurtri je peux tout à fait comprendre
sûr mais effectivement ici il y avait un
côté un peu acting baiser de cinéma
de la même manière que climat aussi
embrassé donc aux voiles arte plus
chaudes mais plus showman je trouve que
c'est bien que gillet dit ça ce soir à
fatou bon pas très bien la merci en tout
cas voilà ça fait partie mine de rien
l'aktu des médias parce que j'ai vu que
ça faisait des titres parus donc voilà
donc vous voulez vous en parler puisque
ça fait partie de l'acte du poste et
gilles tu nous tiendra au courant et
j'espère que tout va bien se passer